hi Leute jetzt nein das nicht meine
Begrüßung hallo hallo
mein Name ist Luca meine lieben Freunde
und herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem Video bei dem wir wer würde eher
Fragen beantworten seit wann bist du so
ruhig und so schüchtern
nichts mehr hochgeladen
ja chill dein Gesicht ist ultra
der Kamera und hat einige wer würde eher
Fragen vorbereitet
perfekt danach wird uns jetzt einige wer
würde eher fragen spontan stellen die
wir beantworten wir haben keine
schildern wer würde eher einem Kind das
Eis klauen
Luca was ist deine lieblingseissorte
wer würde eher eine Karriere am
Ballermann starten
warum ich warum ich weil du kein Bier
trinkst
wer würde eher sich im Urlaub als jemand
anderes ausgeben
ich voll Spaß dran wer würde eher einen
überraschungsurlaub planen ich weiß
schon gemacht habe ja deine Urlaube war
nie eine Überraschung und haben auch
irgendwie nicht stattgefunden weil da
irgendwas verkackt wurde wer würde eher
an einem Dance Battle gewinnen
ich glaube auch so traurig oder also ich
finde ihr beiden tanzt beide nicht gut
ja paar Dinge müssen getan werden
[Musik]
eher aushalten
du bist einfach handysüchtig wenn ich
das nur zum Arbeiten benutzen dürfte
dann auch nicht auch nicht wer würde
eher ein Glas Gurkenwasser essen
du ja ich dachte du findest das voll
ekelhaft ich finde es auch ekelhaft aber
ich dachte so wer würde eher dann ich
esse die Gurken hier auch
du bist Gewürzgurken ja voll lecker boah
nee ich dachte du magst es nicht also
doch ich esse das ist jetzt nicht weil
ich du magst das ja gar nicht der würde
eher den Partner die Füße küssen
boah wir haben beide Füße übertrieben
ja dann würde ich auch nicht nehmen weil
ich habe deine Füße sind nicht so
ekelhaft wie meinte
da würde er über den besten Freund
lästern
wirklich ja safe ich weiß nicht mal wer
dein bester Freund ist
Sandra
wer würde eher sein Haustier
als
Hund auf safe besser behandeln als ein
Kind gefühlt
würde ich nicht in Geburtshilfen er ist
das George
nächste Frage
[Applaus]
ganz klar
wer würde eher
[Musik]
hübsch sein nein
okay nächste Frage wer würde eher sein
Kind zum Spitzensportler putzen nein auf
gar keinen Fall ach so ich dachte du
nimmst meinen Namen nee das würde ich
niemals machen
würdest das nicht machen wenn das mein
Kind später sieht
ich speicher mir das ab mach was du
möchtest egal was mach was dich
glücklich macht habe ich bei meinen
Eltern auch bei dir auch gesagt mach was
du willst dann wurde ich irgendwie das
hier gemacht ich habe Basketball
gespielt
wer würde eher eine Woche schweigen
können
nicht abgucken okay
ich dachte du guckst was ich nehme
Gespräch anfangen so wir sitzen und und
was und ich war Auto Digger
wer würde eher eine gute
geheimagentagentin abgeben
natürlicher boah da würde ich jetzt eure
beide Meinungen zu wissen Sprachen
lernen wer würde eher ohne den anderen
feiern gehen
ich hasse feiern
ich liebe das ohne dich feiern zu gehen
[Musik]
ein Kalender mit den Bildern von sich
selbst shooten oh mein Gott das ist
einfach genügend Bilder dafür wer würde
eher
[Musik]
wow es würde eher alles spüren als OP
durchführen lassen
wer würde eher sich beide Augenbrauen
abrasieren ich muss dazu was sagen ihr
seid beide sehr eigene Person
Luca mehr als ich
aber es wird trotzdem bekommen wer würde
eher eine Gabel essen
Biene Gabel eine Gabel essen
auf der Straße küssen
ich helfe nicht
niemals ja gut
dann nicht der würde eher länger und
besser in reinen sprechen oh mein Gott
das ist einfach die zweite 100% Frage
den Geburtstag des Babys vergessen
14.06
wir waren mal im Urlaub und dann habe
ich beim Tresor unser zusammenkommen
Datum als Code genommen
habe er würde eher dem Kind in die
Schuhe schieben wenn er was im Haus
kaputt geht
[Musik]
klar voll mit doch nicht sprechen kann
nee 100%, du liebst solche Shows du
willst doch die einzige die sich sowas
angucken
in der Nacht vom Flughafen abholen
du bist nicht so sozial ich habe das
erst mitten in der Nacht nicht gehört
und dann dass mir schlaft dann schon
wichtiger
auf einen anderen Kontinent ziehen
auch 100%. nee ich bin happy in
Deutschland das einzige wo ich
auswandern würde wäre Schweiz oder
vielleicht so Dänemark oder irgendwie
sowas von hier nehmen ich will bei
Family bleiben in der Nähe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine Mutter in Urlaub fahren
du würdest es nicht du würdest eher mit
meiner Meinung Urlaub fahren als ich mit
deiner Mom nein ich glaube boah die
Sonne nervt gerade extrem
[Musik]
an der Stelle würden wir das heutige
Video jetzt auch Ben schreibt uns gerne
in die Kommentare
[Musik]